It is my lady. Oh, it is my love. Oh, that she knew that she were,
we brought together seven actors.
I am an actor. I'm an actor. I am an actor. I am an actor. I'm an actor.
I am an actor. I'm a great actor. I'm a confident actor.
There is a liar. If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll win a cash prize. If the liar survives,
they win the entire prize. This is Bob out.
When did you first realize that you wanted to be an actor? Second grade?
I was five when I was in college and I said, he brought in Paris.
That's pretty late. You know.
I'm being honest. You guys are lying. So.
Nobody decides late in life. They want to be an actor.
Otherwise she had to be crazy.
Quick intros on just like what we're doing now. Yeah, that'd be really cool.
Uh, I currently have a web. Is that right now? Angel city heroes.
So check it out. Where can we find that online fit TV network or Google.
At T V network. We're coming down to 20 seconds. Okay.
I also have a web series out called Catlin's Lake.
Do you guys have a TV show out one strange. Happy. Just took it off of Amazon.
Cause we got a distribution deal.
I just finished a guest spot on nine one, one on Fox. Thank you.
I played a creepy guy. Exciting. That was my ride.
I just did a Colgate commercial.
Corporate stuff. I'm doing a lot of corporate stuff. I don't want to say like,
it seemed like he was trying to push the target.
Someone else try to make us less suspicious of him. It looks like an actor.
She sounds like an actor,
but it just seemed like she isn't necessarily pursuing acting.
When we all said, when we've decided to become actors,
she was the only one that made that decision late in life.
Okay.
Quickest role of my career. I was a creepy guy on the show.
Nine 11 on Fox. Maybe they thought I wasn't creepy, which would be flattering.
You know, I'd like to think that, that they all saw me and they said this guy,
he's not creepy. He's he's a nice guy. What was your face.
Today that you've gone? Oh man.
I was just on an episode of the Wonderland murders and a plate,
the murderer for the episode that I was going to be horror movie,
which was a lot of fun. Did you get killed? I did get killed.
I was hacking for a second. Oh, sorry. Spoilers.
Uh, is the one I'm currently doing?
Cause I get to play like a crazy action heroes.
A lot of like fighting and somewhere. Um,
mine was a M stoner rom com. It was on Hulu.
Interesting. Yeah, he's really quiet. Um,
and he didn't really participate in the conversation and he was very,
very vague. Um, I was on a recent episode of shame.
I acted opposite of William H Macy was, was really, really cool. Yeah.
Like the legend is friends, right? He was.
He was an easy, Oh, I thought it was friends. I don't know.
Interesting question though. He just had an interesting energy.
It didn't seem like it was connected to being in the industry being established.
Did you guys, uh, train anyone? Go to school for acting?
I went to performing arts high school. Okay, cool.
I took a couple classes over at, uh, SM CC Santa Monica college. Yeah.
Okay, cool. Has that, is that where it ends or you have a future?
I think I learned what I needed to learn. So now I'm just auditioning, you know,
all you guys, you know? Oh, we're out of time.
Oh,
something didn't really feel right.
But he just didn't seem as like,
as part of the group kind of made me wonder if he knew what we were talking
about.
I'm a working actor. I'm a great actor. I'm a confident actor.
So much love to everybody, right?
Yeah. Nothing against anyone. Are you guys familiar with Romeo and Juliet? Yeah,
totally. Yeah. But soft. What light through yonder window breaks.
It is the East end. Juliet is the sun arise,
fair sun and kill. The envy is smooth.
Who is already sick and pale with grief that thou art the,
Oh, of course.
There's a great way to tell if you're an actor because you can emote at the
right time while you're reading.
It's fair to say that you know what you're doing?
None but falls to where it cast it off.
It is my lady. Oh, it is my love. Oh,
but she knew that she works
over Romeo Romeo where art thou Romeo.
So there's been a tie between two people, Molly and Reese. Wow.
So we're going to do a rebuilt.
I vote between those two. Oh, okay. Sorry. Can I redo mine?
Sorry. I'm sorry. Super loud.
We can end the game now. Or do you feel like the mall is still in the box?
We should get it. I think we have. We should continue. We should continue.
I think so. We're going to be shocked at the end. We're going to be surprised.
We were really vibing. We had a great energy and that is what threw me off.
That's what kind of put up the red flag in my head.
If the lights turn green, voted out
red box, you can call people. Yeah. Okay.
[Inaudible].
Will please step forward now.
Right away. I got a man. I thought it was you. I thought it was him.
Yes. I'm not playing. I apparently played the game wrong.
I picked you both times. I thought that was the point
I made everybody believe me. I think I should have won.
Took the whole 400 because I fooled everybody.
I basically out acted everyone. And I guarantee you,
if we asked who the mole was, everybody would have picked me at first.
I was a little embarrassed because I was like, it's that obvious.
And then I kind of watched them pick one each other apart. And I was like, Oh,
this is fantastic. Like entertainment wise. I'm so happy. I went out right away.
They would have figured it out.
Like I can act if I had to do the Romeo and Juliet thing,
they would've known right then and there,
I felt very unprepared about Romeo and Juliet. It's a whole nother skill.
Almost like you have film, you have theater and then you have Shakespeare.
I'm really, really proud of everyone else. Apparently not me because, uh,
I, I didn't know who the mole was.
First game show up in on first time I won. So I'm one for one. So, you know,
that's pretty cool. So yes,
I'm the winner and I hate to say it,
but I out acted and outsmarted everybody up on the stage.
I'm going to be thanked for coffee and ones for like three months.